ah
[Music]
it took hundreds of thousands of years
for the human population to reach 1
billion and in less than 200 years that
has increased to nearly 7.5 billion
people many scientists calculate the
sustainable population to be about 2
billion people which means we need to
manage our resources and food production
very carefully to cater to the extra 5.5
billion people as populations have grown
farming practices have become more
intensified to maximize crop yield and
ensure that we can feed our ever-growing
population fertilizers and pesticides
are used on crops and animals may be
kept inside in more densely packed sheds
to maximize milk yields or egg
production or speed up the time needed
for the animal to be ready to be sent to
the market for meat to learn more about
conventional farming watch our video on
modern agriculture in this video we are
going to look at an alternative to
conventional farming organic farm
they're going to see what it is in
theory and the pros and cons of this
method in relation to other modern
agricultural methods organic farming
currently accounts for about 1% of
agricultural land worldwide it focuses
on sustainability and is thought to have
less detrimental effects on the
environment than conventional farming
this is led to it being proposed as an
alternative to conventional agriculture
for helping to overcome the climate
change crisis we are currently
experiencing but the debate continues as
it is not a perfect solution in Syria
organic farming should not use chemical
fertilizers herbicides and pesticides or
feed additives for livestock it requires
the former to use more natural
alternatives this results in low heels
of the Pharmakon sell their product at a
higher price because consumers believes
the product is of a higher quality
instead of fertilizers the newer is used
this recycles waste and improves the
sort of structure however it is smelly
and more difficult to apply than
chemical fertilizers and also means the
farmer has less control over the mineral
content they are putting into their soil
crop rotation is used to reduce diseases
building up in the soils and to
strengthen the soil composition certain
crops and such as of the green family so
pins and beans fix nitrogen from the air
and increase
nitrate from the soil this makes this
were much more fertile and so farmers
rotate legumes with their other crops
growing multiple crops is however less
efficient and produces lower yields than
specializing in one or fewer crops
instead of using herbicides reading is
the preferred organic farming technique
this is of course much more
environmentally friendly because it is
chemical free but it is very
labor-intensive although this does mean
more jobs available which is a great
thing organic farming is thought to
maintain the biodiversity that is in
conventional farming because fewer
chemicals are used there are more
bumblebees and insects in the area
because pesticides haven't been used we
the non crop plants can grow as
certified values biodiversity benefits
the food chain across all levels from
the plants up to the Foxes these are the
theories of organic farming and is how
we farmed for 100,000 years before the
Industrial Revolution it is generally
thought that organic farming is much
better for biodiversity and also
produces a healthier product because
less chemicals are used on it in the
second video on organic farming we will
look at some of the problems of organic
farming and the reality of what it means
to be an organic farm
[Music]
[Applause]